one of the the mission statements of
Baltimore uh teachers union is to
enhance the quality of education for
black for students in the city and
that's not being done I would categorize
it as a a system of complacency and so
yeah being money hungry without actually
putting out the results um that's that
we're supposed to be putting out
project Baltimore has done such amazing
uh journalism in investigative
journalism on exposing um Baltimore city
schools and just the Dismal outcomes for
black students in a recent report that
they just found is that the the
Baltimore uh teachers union is getting
millions of dollars when student
outcomes have continued to decline and
most recently they got an up ticket and
the amount of money that they are
getting it was heartbreaking I was
totally surprised um
because the kids are graduating from
high school not knowing how to read
they're being
direct shipped directly into the
criminal justice system and it's
disheartening especially when there is
an organization that's supposed to be
created to implement strategies to
increase education opportunities however
that's not being done a a lot of people
get confused when we talk about the
teachers union and they believe that
we're talking about teachers but we're
not discussing teachers the teachers
unions is our political organization and
all of their Affiliates that's set up to
fund and and Lobby organizations and one
of the main things that they do is fund
the the Democratic party everyone should
know that this is a special interest
group um that's trying to to bring our
students down to be quite Frank the
teachers Union was a funer of the black
lives matter movement and that's why I
started our organization black minds
matter because I saw that there was a a
facade of morality um going around and
in real um strategies to correct
deep-seated in injustices such as the
education system was not being addressed
it's it's it's abysmal and you have to
think where the corruption lies um they
constantly come out saying that they do
not support school choice they don't
support increasing education
opportunities for students Empirical
research studies have seen that students
especially black and brown kids who go
to Charter Schools and private schools
have significantly better education
outcomes than students who stay in
traditional Public Schools the only
bandage to um increasing education
outcomes in the traditional Public
School space is to increase funding you
know to give more money more money more
money into the system but the average
per pupil expenditure in Baltimore city
schools is
22 ,000 per kit per year and so more
money has not increased education
outcomes for students in the state and
especially in Baltimore City Schools
they're profiting off of our kids
they're profiting off of you know just
the dismo outcomes for black and brown
students in the city and one of the
remedies is to give that money to
parents they're programs that are now
expanding freedom to allow parents to
use their education dollars however they
see it if that's to buy books and
pencils tutoring Services um pay tuition
but it doesn't have to be for that and
that's what we need to do for for
students instead of dumping all the
money into the teachers union the
legislature should ensure that the
monies that going in in funding this
Union is not being taken from the public
school coffers teacher pay is always
being lobbied at the state so what how
how are they getting more money you know
we have this system of public education
educating the public and in Choice
programs that's there's this
accountability Factor already baked in
but when we don't hold Public Schools
accountable for educating our kids we're
just setting them up for failure we have
to hold them accountable
[Music]